How to deal with people who dominate the
conversation? I have dealt with this so
much in my work. I've learned some really clever
techniques, I've made some stumbles, blunders and
failures and in this video, I'm going to show you
3 of my favorite methods for... in the gentlest,
most loving possible way, quieting people down
who tend to dominate conversation to create
space for all voices to be heard. This is really
good if you have any interest in creating more
psychologically safe and inclusive environments
in your own educational leadership group context.
I'm Chad Littlefield, let's get into it.
A big part of my past work
experience had led me to
creating We and Me, these video tutorials, being
invited to speak and facilitate workshops all
around the country, was working with this group
called World In Conversation where my job was to
sit in over 500 dialogues and lead
conversations with groups of 6 to 10 people
on topics that were fairly contentious, race
relations, long-term conflict, gender, politics etc.
Very frequently, somebody would really dominate
those conversations and it might be, you know, they
might not have bad intentions, they might just
like really love to talk and they love to hear
the sound of their own voice or they're really
passionate about a particular topic and they're
just constantly sharing, which is, it's not always
bad, but it is bad when it suppresses other voices.
To be a little bit vulnerable in this moment,
like, I love to share,  love to talk and so I'm
recognizing that even as I'm recording this video
sometimes, I am the monopolizer. And so, I've learned
through some deep empathy how to really re-guide
and direct traffic toward all voices in a room,
not just the monopolizer, not just the person who
dominates a conversation. I'm gonna call my first
strategy Flip the Roles. This is so easy to do
and it is so powerful. All I do in a group...
so let's say we're having a conversation, it could
be virtual could be in-person, and noticing that
somebody's really dominating the conversation
and I'm about to ask for people to participate
or share, ask people's perspective, all I'm gonna do
is say, "Hey, this time when I ask you the question
'what struck you about those conversations?' or 'what
struck you about that last meeting?' or 'what do you
think about this?'" When I'm about to do that, right
before I ask that question, I say, "If you typically
are the first person to speak or one of the first
3 people to speak, hold off and be like the
8th person to speak and it's possible you might
not get a chance to speak this time, but I'd love
to hear some of the voices that don't always
get heard." And so, did you see what I did there?
People who talk a lot, know they talk a lot,
and so I just said flip the roles. I didn't
say, "We don't want to hear from you," I said, "We'd
love to hear from you, but not in a way of like
hey if you haven't spoken yet, like hey, like Sandra
and Mark and Jamal, I haven't heard from either of
the 3 of you, can you like figure this out and
share something," right? No, I'm not putting them on
the spot. I'm inviting loud people to be quieter
by saying that I'd love to hear from other people.
That simple flip the role is so powerful.
Now, related to that is a technique that I
would call Creating Space, and like space, like
outer space, it's silent. And sometimes if you
leave just a little bit of silence, it creates
enough of a moment for someone who tends to be
a little bit more hesitant to share to actually
share. And so, one of the ways that I create space
is by saying, you know, and I really think that the
best way to avoid awkward silence is to create
productive silence, and so one of the ways that
I would create space with a group is just to say,
"Hey, I'm going to ask you a question.
I'd love to get all of your responses.
If you tend to be the first person to speak, hold
off and maybe be the 3rd, 4th or 5th person
to speak because I'd love to hear from everybody
in the group. I'm going to ask you this question
and then I would love to just pause in
total silence for 5 seconds to wait
for everybody to think of their own response
before we popcorn out a handful of responses."
And then I share and in that 5 seconds,
you've created enough space for the people
that are a little bit more hesitant to say, "Okay, I
think this is what I want to say," and they
jump in, right? And even if no one shares in that
5 seconds, let that time sit. It is such a good
exercise for monopolizers to just sit there and
bear through silence and also if it gets really
bad, I might reflect back to the monopolizers that
they're like, "Well, there's so much silence, I just,
I had to jump in and say something." I might reflect
back to them and was like, "It was actually only 4
seconds of quiet and so let's do this one more
time and let's just take 10 seconds of total
silence and get everybody a proper chance to think."
Not everybody gets ready to speak as quickly as
some. The 2nd technique that I'm going to share
with you is inviting you to change the mechanics.
If there's somebody monopolizing conversation or
dominating a conversation, it might be because of
them, but it also might becauseof
your structure. If you're meeting in a large
group of 12 people, you're breaking Amazon's 2
pizza rule which is never have more people at a
meeting than 2 pizzas can feed. And
so, that structure would be lousy. If there's
too many cooks in the kitchen, you're just
asking for somebody to dominate and take over
and asking for everybody else to just sit into
the role of consumer. And so, when I say "change
the mechanics," what I mean by that is split
out into groups of 3 to have discussions
and then come back and report out what
you heard other people in your group say,
not what you said. Because when you have people
report out what other people said, the monopolizers
don't go quite as crazy with other people's words
as with their own. Whereas if you are asking for
their opinion, they'll give you that for days on
days. 3rd technique here, and we're starting
to get down to the wire, we're starting to get down
to the place where like if the first 2 ideas or
techniques didn't work, the 2nd one is a little
bit more of a direct approach, it's very effective,
there's a a really gentle kind way to do it
and then there's a blunt way that is like kind
of my last ditch. Not last ditch effort, it's my
strategic way and this is steering into the curve.
So, if you're not familiar with that metaphor,
ifyou're in a car and it's spinning
out of control on icy roads or something around
a curve, you want to steer into the curve, which
is very counterintuitive, right? You're actually
going to what feels like toward danger to get
yourself realigned. And if that metaphor's not
working for you, pointing out the elephant
in the room is this idea. And so, just actually
calling out the dynamic privately first. So,, this is
a gentle loving way to... if you notice somebody's
like really dominating every conversation,
to pull somebody aside and use technique
number 1 in private one-on-one with the
person dominating. And so, actually look at them and
say, "Hey, what I'd love for you to do... I'm loving all
your contributions and I'm recognizing that your
contributions are heavier than other people's and
I want to make space for other people's voices.
And so, can you aim to just like bear through
a little bit of awkward silence to give space for
other people to share for the rest of our day
or for the rest of our session etc.?" That could be
done if you have some trust and rapport with them,
that can be done in direct message over Zoom, that
could be done in a side conversation on a break.
You choose how to do that, but that private
check-in, steering to the curve and just pointing
out the dynamic because guess what? You're not
going to surprise them. It's like, I once worked...
I did a this whole team development program with
a group of students who were blind and I was like,
"Oh my gosh like I'm not blind, this is
so not normal." And I realized like they taught me,
"Oh, this is totally normal for them." Like me
pointing out that they're blind or that they're
visually impaired is not news to them. So, pointing
out to somebody who's dominating a conversation
that they're dominating a conversation isn't news
to them, right? You're not going to shock
them, you're not going to like, make them enrage,
they're not going to spin off and go crazy because
you shared that. And the 2nd way to steer into
the curve or point at the elephant in the room
is to do that publicly in front of the group and
I'd be really mindful of this and I'll share an
example of how I did this recently. It was a bit
of a risk. So, I was in a workshop and it was about
80% women and 4 guys, all of them were
white and there were a handful of people color on
the call as well. I was noticing that me and Will
who were facilitating, my co-founder, were talking a
bunch and then this one other person who was also
a white guy was talking a bunch and what came to
me in that moment when he went to speak, and he
was kind of dominating the conversation a little
bit, not a bad way. It was great contributions,
but his voice was heavier and I said, and he
wouldn't mind me sharing this, his name's Jason.
I just said, "Hey, Jason. Quick pause. I recognize
we're playing white guy ping pong right now. I'd
love to create some space to hear other voices in
the group." After that conversation I had multiple
individuals message me and say, "Oh my gosh. I never
heard a white guy call out other white guys for
playing white guy ping pong like that, that was so
awesome. I felt so heard and seen and it allowed
and created a space for my voice." And so, that's
an example of how I might publicly acknowledge
that in also a really loving way though. If you
love creating awesome conversations, you would
love this book and all the tools that we have
available for free digital download in the link
below I'm Chad Littlefield, have an awesome day.